Yipes is Marvel vs. Capcom he's an Evo
champion the voice of fighting games for
an entire generation of player even
after Marvel faded away japes kept its
flame burning and in the game's darkest
hour 20 years after it first came out
the ice brought a dead game back to life
started playing fighting games in 2003
and while that might sound the late for
one of the scenes oh geez
he actually started out as an FPS player
but after his computer broke down
yipeee started to head out to the arcade
and try something new Yipes fell in love
with Marvel vs. Capcom 2 the game was
explosive
but deep accessible but incredibly
complex for Apes it was the perfect
fighting game you would literally sit
there for like an hour even days on end
I used to lose sleep on Marvel to like
then we times I wouldn't even sleep for
like a day and a half eventually the ice
outgrew his first arcade and moved on to
the legendary Chinatown fare it's like
when you go to like other arcades or
like your corner stores that play games
people come so hey man like you're good
but you ever been to Chinatown they got
really big arcade to go Chinese out
there and like that's where all the best
players play even if you've never been a
childhood favorite before you know that
that place exists and it's like
legendary Chinatown fit and want to see
that's literally where I met all of my
closest friends and it would change my
life forever
for Yates and the other oh jeez
competing was just for fun
and glory prizes were very small and
people didn't really travel the country
to become the best in the world it was a
time when regional rivalries reigned
supreme
usually when I'm nervous is when I have
that pressure of representing my Coast
so for example like if I know this
something that's something big on the
line when I realized that like I have a
whole Coast behind me really watching my
back and I don't
want to let them down yeah when I start
really getting into that mind state
that's when I start getting nervous but
I didn't know that that East Coast West
Coast like really serious I didn't know
so tournaments were for glory but the
cash came from money matches hey come
out of work and just put how would the
mechanics of it go down would you put
the money on it let's go let's go first
four five fifty on honey
five ten fifteen Porter's pennies
whatever losers broke that the done but
not broke but you know yeah one you get
any any type of news changing food the
winner that is
Yipes was consumed by marvel it wasn't
just his favorite fighting game it was
his life and in 2007
Yipes won evo beating justin wong the
best player to ever touch the game yeah
this is really good Amaro to UM you
always have to quit like a hundred and
twenty percent when you're when you're
fighting against him just because if he
touched you once you might not actually
get to play ever again I would say that
he's my hardest opponent that I would
have to fight in tomorrow's kakum series
but when Yankel wasn't on stage he was
in the back commentating with his
friends and he invented some phrases
that commentators used to this day
[Applause]
if you were to make a MVC to Mount
Rushmore the ice would be on it in fact
in the 10 years of Evo ran Marvel 2
there were only four champions and
Heights was one of them so and this is
no disrespect to nobody on that list but
ain't nobody on Ellis Kumi period if
there's only three people that could
defeat me in this game currently which
is duck justin sanford no one else
stands a chance
but Marvel's popularity was constantly
waiting and when Street Fighter 4 the
game that brought the FCC back to life
came out it was whole but dead in 2008 I
still remember at one point looking
around the room and going I know like
almost everybody here like I'm not
seeing new faces but the game that
really ended marble to tournament life
was it Marvel vs. Capcom 3 it was the
game that wasn't supposed to happen but
it was huge people loved it and for a
time it even overtook Street Fighter as
the biggest game in the FCC and of
course the ice turned up both to compete
and commentate but the FCC was changing
over the course of Marvel threes
lifespan eSports began to take root in
the FCC which meant that gritty
old-school vibe that yips grew up with
was starting to fade away I quite
frankly don't care about eSports that's
just me I came in the arcade era I come
from a rough gritty side of things when
it came to that DC and that made it very
authentic for me and I made it more fun
the thing that worries me is that the
authenticity of it is going to get taken
away and I'm saying to the point where
we can't even have fun no more is just
get on the stage get the job done get
the [ __ ] out and then that's it we'll
see you later peace out
so we Abe's created his own tournament
one that would let all these new Marvel
3 players enjoy the kinds of regional
rivalries that he grew up with but just
like its older brother
Marvel 3 began to decline after a few
years Yipes began to play and commentate
other games Dragon Well fighters Street
Fighter 5 until eventually Marvel 3
wasn't even an Evo by 2018 the Marvel
community was a shadow of its former
self
most players had moved on leaving the
diehards without any huge tournaments to
compete in and the game that caused
Marvel decline was its own sequel when
you just look at it it just it doesn't
look as polished like even a character
select screen the lags but I mean I do
think overall like a game is good it's
just that it also came out during the
same time as drying off fighter Z so
when you look at two games and you're
like should I play Lawrence crack-up or
Dragon Ball Fighter Z you're obviously
going to choose Dragon Ball fighter Z
between the poor graphics disappointing
roster and competition from Dragonball
fighters Marvel vs. Capcom infinite
never really took off Evo didn't put in
the lineup the year it came out and
eventually Capcom just kind of abandoned
it
Marvel just we know it was on a slippery
slope and it had a lot of competition
going forward and it just kind of
fizzled I it was the main game for eight
straight years like it was crazy but I
don't think people are playing and
that's the problems we always had to
support games that people actually play
it just it didn't make the cut this year
yeah it started to host his own marble
tournament but not just any Marvel game
Marvel - he called the tournament battle
of the strongest - named after a
legendary match he played back in the
day the tournament was just 10 Marvel -
oh geez duking it out in some dudes
basement with the Apes and his friends
commentating by all accounts it should
have been a weird one-off blip something
that only the old heads could have ever
cared about but instead everyone loved
it that was that was ODP
camera camera camera that was OTP yo I
don't think he meant it to get this big
it just organically happened that way
my you think they're still doing petals
stronger than a basement right kind of
brings that love and like that
uniqueness of just like this is how a
moral to was back that day and I think
it's because like sometimes I know
obviously he's four C's pours right but
there's times where we just kind of want
to go back to our roots and play the
games we love and that's kind of what
yeah it's like bow as strong as like
feels like but yeah I mean it played out
great you know what I what I appreciated
the most from that event is obvious I
was doing it with the homies but the
fact that everybody generally enjoyed it
back at home like this [ __ ] was crazy
like I'm talking about everywhere I went
afterwards people was talking about bats
and bats bats this time I yelled like I
know like it really touched it up my dad
name is folks organizers to tournament
organizers that do big events and stuff
like then there was just like oh man
like that was so so real so authentic
like I ever see something like that a
while
the tournament was such a huge success
that Yates had to bring it back for 2019
[Music]
oh that was Jake's brought back the kind
of tournaments that today's legends grew
up with and that newer players have
never gone to experienced battle the
strongest four seemed like a lock but
nobody could have expected what happened
next but we got one little special
surprise here see this is so we got we
got a big anniversary this year
it's a 20th anniversary of a game that
has been in our tournaments past and it
was very popular I have no idea what
game it is Marvel vs. Capcom 2 stupid a
mad tournament okay four of the people
yeah are invited to this tournament and
these four people are the people that
have won evo mm-hmm
so that would be justin wong okay VIP
yes one that would be ducked oh oh yeah
this one and sanford Kelly hahaha
they're all invited to this invitational
evo in 2020 we don't know for sure if
evo is putting on a Marvel to tournament
because of Battle of the strongest but
it doesn't really care about getting the
credit he just wants to give back to the
community that he's been a part of for
almost twenty years no matter how I'm
seen in that you see whether it's a
competitor commentate as long as this as
long as I'm helping helping with growing
the scene in a positive and and more
energetic fire then that's fine with me
and I'm saying cuz a lot of people hold
this ego this strength about the past
and whatever the case is I'm not about
that [ __ ] right I did what I did I
cemented my [ __ ] in history that's it
let's move forward and I mean Marvel vs.
Capcom 2 may be 20 years old but as long
as guys like you apes are around it'll
never die thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
you